hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys so
today we're checking out a trailer for a
film called chocolate city I saw the
thumbnail for it it was a guy shirtless
it's rated r for sexual content
throughout partial nudity language and
brief violence your type of movie my
type of movie I just wish there was more
nudity let's see what this movies about
we saw fence he's black guy says minions
fancy net is not tyrelle Magnus we gonna
add little shop yeah what do you let me
take you out this weekend you don't even
have a car gonna pick me up on your bike
yeah here's your change it's gonna be
tight around here for the next few
months my schedules because what
happened to dude you met the other night
he said yeah job I manage this place
people
oh Basset like it Scooby fine lady was
Amateur Night
get dressed Your Honor to what's his
name Magic Mike black people yeah exact
same every day another be named know
better
Magic Mike both of us tell em exactly
whoever created that said what if Magic
Mike was about black people that it does
look sexy though it does look sexy I
like the lead guys seen him in something
and he looks familiar is he that like
it's he that convict they got a model
deal from that head if you're wrong oh
man I'm shot no man looks like that mug
shot guy I mean I know it's not him but
he looks like that guy what stereotyping
in such a bad way you know like they
know i'm talking about it was like it's
like a light-skinned black ever with
like blue eyes it's amazing well are
just not brown eyes I hope you're right
I like someone has to agree to meet
agree with me that he looks like that
that mug shot guy uh-huh what no it's
really good looking like I watch it for
him yeah vivica a fox when I go to the
theaters I want to be the only one not
black in there kind of like how it is
with the reactor world I feel like it
would be a really fun we were you seen
the movie theaters I feel like the
audience would just be like insanely
funny yeah I would love to go baked out
of my mind I would love to get lost in
this world a black magic like chocolate
yeah oh my god not eating that movie and
eat chocolate or watching it looks like
Magic Mike total rip off with a more
cliche storyline that's it this is a
solid she came out in the cowboy attire
I was like that's that's frickin this
really so now male exotic dancers and
like oh you're new I got a new job for
you what is this world all right I'm
making a [ __ ] ton of money nap like it's
it's the exact same [ __ ] moving your
mom with his different money yeah yeah I
mean there's nothing wrong with being a
stripper so I think it's a fun time this
movie looks like a fun time definitely
not a movie I'd pay to see a movie
theatres but it's when I go on redbox
with my girlfriends and
like eat ice cream too and laugh and
have fun yeah jerk off and watch it
really okay yeah do your thing yeah I
mean I'm not gay I could be though I
mean there were a lot of really sexy
girls in that movie though too I will
admit when I find a guy is attractive
they usually are muscular like I'm
attracted in muscles usually like when
are you not Lee Jerry no I mean some guy
some guys are just like oh he's handsome
he's cute I have to see their body first
before I say yeah he's trapped and all
these black guys are so attractive yeah
they all look like Tyrone Magnus just
big buff black and beautiful i hope this
video gets us more black subscribers
definitely we need more we need more we
need more black subscribers and more 13
year old subscribers you frame and I
think this video is gonna do it for us
anyway rating system time I am
definitely going to wait till it's on
DVD anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can sub to the real rejects
salamander sally has a channel a lot of
fun [ __ ] on there check it out as soon
as you can and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter you know
I ran out of things to say I just want a
product placement it's my product
placement you just wants all the money I
would love it if coca-cola was like
tweet about us Emily 25 grand I just had
an audition for Cooper cool actually
really though they're the best soda in
the world hey I take it every day yeah
we both develop type 2 diabetes and I
clean my toilet with eggs as such bad
chemical done